customizing your ride so we're going to
try to celebrate that as long and it
also have a little bit fun this week
during games com we want you all to help
to create the perfect need for speed car
here's the deal go to acne for speed on
twitter choose between one of two
classic Porsches 911s then picks it pick
the rims the wing the body kits and even
the rap but that is just the start we
are going to build this car in real life
that's right in real life with our build
icon nakai son and we go to reveal this
car at SEMA Show in Las Vegas in
November and if you participate you'll
have a chance to win and right along in
that car in Vegas that you helped create
good so with that the shift gears and
meet the stars of the game the icons of
need for speed I knew what I wanted but
then when I got the car then it changed
something you throw caution to the wind
you just go for it once I'm behind the
wheel literally nothing else matters you
know you push yourself to the limit and
beyond for me style is just a part of
life and you either do it or you don't
do it but there's nothing else like that
feeling of being able to control a car
can't really get much better than this
you don't if I'm in the state taking it
movie together what is the pattern it
could my like any view as a European de
gallo sniffing of pure imagination how
good these trucks will be empty for all
night so glitter just hang out there and
start zigzagging through side streets
have found an open garage and i pulled
into someone's garage it was I couldn't
believe I got away with it malodorous
bangkok wake up do you know who I can I
mean idea so this is it kata-kata oddest
two amazing things I can't feel any
worse in my life we've all got a link to
scream this November
you